can I see
[Music]
I'm awesome
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Spooner some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it you ratted
us out hey don't use that word that way
I mean it's 20 25 already dead
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
[Music]
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdomness Raphael
you have bravery and Leonardo honored
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
when I'm shooting